imagine you're the owner of a small
software development firm and you want
to scale your business up however a
small team size the unpredictability of
demand and limited resources are
roadblocks for this expansion
that's when you hear about cloud
computing but before investing money
into it you decide to draw up the
differences between on-premise and
cloud-based computing to make a better
decision
when it comes to scalability you pay
more for an on-premise setup and get
lesser options too
once you've scaled up it is difficult to
scale down
and often leads to heavy losses in terms
of infrastructure and maintenance costs
cloud computing on the other hand allows
you to pay only for how much you use
with much easier and faster provisions
for scaling up or down
next let's talk about server storage
on-premise systems need a lot of space
for their servers notwithstanding the
power and maintenance hassles that come
with them
on the other hand cloud computing
solutions are offered by cloud service
providers who manage and maintain the
servers saving you both money and space
then we have data security on-premise
systems offer less data security thanks
to a complicated combination of physical
and traditional i.t security measures
whereas cloud computing systems offer
much better security and lets you avoid
having to constantly monitor and manage
security protocols
in the event that a data loss does occur
the chance for data recovery with
on-premise setups are very small
in contrast cloud computing systems have
robust disaster recovery measures in
place to ensure faster and easier data
recovery
finally we have maintenance
on-premises systems also require
additional teams for hardware and
software maintenance loading up the
costs by a considerable degree
cloud computing systems on the other
hand are maintained by the cloud service
providers reducing your costs and
resource allocation substantially
so now thinking that cloud computing is
a better option you decide to take a
closer look at what exactly cloud
computing is
cloud computing refers to the delivery
of on-demand computing services over the
internet on a pay-as-you-go basis
in simpler words rather than managing
files and services on a local storage
device you'll be doing the same over the
internet in a cost efficient manner
cloud computing has two types of models
deployment model and service model
there are three types of deployment
models public private and hybrid cloud
imagine you're traveling to work you've
got three options to choose from
one you have buses which represent
public clouds in this case the cloud
infrastructure is available to the
public over the internet
these are owned by cloud service
providers
two then you have the option of using
your own car
this represents the private cloud with
the private cloud the cloud
infrastructure is exclusively operated
by a single organization this can be
managed by the organization or a third
party and finally you have the option to
hail a cab
this represents the hybrid cloud
a hybrid cloud is a combination of the
functionalities of both public and
private clouds
next let's have a look at the service
models
there are three major service models
available es pass and sas
compared to on-premise models where
you'll need to manage and maintain every
component including applications data
virtualization and middleware cloud
computing service models are hassle-free
is refers to infrastructure as a service
it is a cloud service model where users
get access to basic computing
infrastructure they are commonly used by
it administrators
if your organization requires resources
like storage or virtual machines is is
the model for you you'll only have to
manage the data runtime middleware
applications and the os while the rest
is handled by the cloud providers
next we have pass
pass or platform as a service provides
cloud platforms and runtime environments
for developing testing and managing
applications
this service model enables users to
deploy applications without the need to
acquire manage and maintain the related
architecture
if your organization is in need of a
platform for creating software
applications pass is the model for you
pass only requires you to handle the
applications and the data the rest of
the components like runtime middleware
operating systems servers storage and
others are handled by the cloud service
providers
and finally we have sas
sas or software as a service involves
cloud services for hosting and managing
your software applications
software and hardware requirements are
satisfied by the vendors so you don't
have to manage any of those aspects of
the solution
if you'd rather not worry about the
hassles of owning any it equipment the
sas model would be the one to go with
with sas the cloud service provider
handles all components of the solution
required by the organization
time for a quiz now
in which of the following deployment
models are you as the business
responsible for the application data and
operating system
one is
two
pass
three
sas
four is and pass
let us know your answer in the comments
section below in this session we learn
about google cloud platform wherein we
will learn about what is cloud computing
why google cloud platform what is gcp
that is google cloud platform
google cloud platform domains
about a use case that is federal use
case and also a quick demo on using
services from google cloud platform so
when we talk about google cloud platform
we also need to know what is cloud
computing so cloud computing is the use
of hardware and software components to
deliver a service to a network
users can access these files and
applications
and services provided by a cloud
provider
from any device that has access to
internet
in short cloud computing is a way where
cloud provider provides
access to different services such as
resources and when we talk about
resources here we talk about computing
we talk about memory we talk about
processing power we talk about storage
and we also talk about different
services which cloud providers make
available for the users now that
allows us for automatic software
integration
backup and restoring data unlimited
storage capacity having a reliable use
of different services and
having a cost efficient solution
now we know that cloud computing
models there are different service
models so you have platform as a service
you have infrastructure as a service and
you have software as a service and these
are the prominent models which are
offered by different cloud providers
such as google cloud
such as google you have amazon you have
azure and also some organizations build
their own private clouds using open
source openstack
let's focus more on google cloud
platform and what it has to offer and
how it is gaining popularity in the
market with different organizations
which would want to work on a cloud
platform or which would want to work
on
an
infrastructure which is modernized so
when we talk about cloud computing this
is one of the approach which
organizations can take to
instantaneously benefit from
modernization using different services
different platforms and also newer
technologies
for their various requirements such as
scalability or dynamic businesses
before we get into google cloud platform
it is also
good to understand
where you can find some useful resources
about google cloud platform and here you
have a website which is
from your google cloud so this is
cloudacademy.com
slash library slash google and here you
can create a free account now that would
give you just seven days trial but that
has a lot of
videos which talk about your google
cloud platform and essentials and it has
various certification related videos
which you can access and then after
seven days after you have tried you can
obviously go for a paid account where
you can take detailed learning from here
now this is your training library which
shows your different cloud providers
such as amazon microsoft seo
gcp and then you have various other
topics which are specifics to
organization
you can obviously look at the pricing
and you can also look at resources which
will give you a good
experience in learning from these videos
you can also create a free account which
i will walk you through later so you can
create a free account on
cloud.google.com now when i say free
account that basically means it allows
you to create an account and every user
who creates an account gets a 300 free
credit which can be used to practice
brush up your skills and also explore
and learn about different
google cloud products which are offered
by google
now coming back to our google cloud
platform let's understand why google
cloud platform
so google cloud platform is popular for
many reasons now let us see a few of
most important reasons why it stands out
when you talk about pricing pricing is
one of the significant factors that make
google cloud stand out among the other
cloud providers
it offers a monthly pricing plan which
is billed according to monthly usage and
when we talk about billing here the
billing can be in hours it can be in
minutes and it can also be in seconds
there are different options when you
talk about your pricing which can be
found from your google cloud web page
now pricing could be
based on preemptive machines pricing
could be based on reserved instances or
reserved resources i'll show you the
link where you can find more details on
pricing part of it
so
google cloud really has
various pricing options which help
customers in their different
requirements whether they would go for
any of the service models such as
infrastructure as a service platform as
a service or even software as a service
one more attractive thing about google
cloud pricing is that it provides
committed use discounts
for example under this scheme you can
purchase a specific amount of virtual
cpu cores and memory for up to 57
percent discount off
regular prices if you commit usage for
either one or three years now this is
just one option there are various such
options which you can learn about from
the google cloud's page
and that really suits
different customers for that different
requirements
now when we talk about speed we don't
need to really challenge this aspect
when it comes to google services so
google provides its google cloud and
google app customer speed up to 10
terabytes because of its faster cable
system there are different kind of
machines which can be used if you are
talking about computation if you are
talking about memory hungry applications
or even storage intensive workloads
all in all speed is one of the defining
characteristics of google cloud services
the cable has connections over u.s west
coast
main cities in japan and even major hubs
in asia this speed enhances performances
and leads to customer satisfaction now
when we talk about customers any or
every customer would prefer to have low
latency
high throughput based services they
would want to use higher speeds to
process their data in as less time as
possible google provides a low latency
network infrastructure in fact you can
say that when you are using google cloud
services you are using the services from
the same infrastructure which google
uses for its popular services such as
google search or even youtube which is
one of the second largest repository
which can be accessed for videos now
when we talk about big data big data is
data which is
very complex has lot of other
characteristics such as
your volume you have velocity you have
variety you have veracity validity
volatility virality and so on so if an
organization has is working on big data
google cloud can be a better choice
because google has many innovative tools
for cloud warehousing for example such
as bigquery and even real-time data
processing tools such as data flow
bigquery is a data warehouse that allows
massive processing of data at high
speeds
basically working on your structured
data google also has launched some new
machine learning from artificial
intelligence tools now there are various
other services which we can which we can
use from google cloud platform but let's
understand what is google cloud platform
and what are some of the services
even the services which are not listed
here can be found in your console from
google cloud so what is google cloud
platform gcp
it is a set of cloud computing services
provided by google that runs on the same
infrastructure as i mentioned that
google uses for its end user products
like youtube gmail and even google
search the various set of services
offered by google cloud platform are so
you have services which are specific to
computing requirements and again in
computing you have
various different options available you
have machines which are compute
optimized machines which are memory
optimized machines which are storage
optimized and also we have certain
machines such as pre m tiff which
basically means that you could get a
machine
to work on at a far lesser price than
any other machine but when we talk about
preemptive these are the machines which
can be requested on demand and they can
be taken back by google at any time you
have networking related services
which can be very useful when you are
setting up your applications or your
services across globe you also have
different services which are specific to
machine learning and organizations which
would be interested in working on
machine learning or artificial
intelligence would be really interested
in using these services there are also
innovative solutions to work on big data
and big data related technologies
now when we talk about google cloud
platform domains so we can break down
these services into specifics such as
you have compute
now the compute service allows for
computing and hosting
the cloud
now when you talk about computing here
there are different services
such as app engine you have compute
engine you have kubernetes you have
cloud functions and cloud run when you
talk about storage and database so the
storage and database service allows
application to store media files backups
or other file like objects now various
services under this are as follows you
have cloud storage cloud sql cloud big
table for unstructured data you have
cloud spanner cloud data store
persistent disks and cloud memory store
when we talk about networking the
networking service allows us to load
balance traffic across resources now as
i mentioned earlier resources could be
your different resources which you would
be using from a cloud platform such as
your devices your instances memory
optimized or cpu optimized instances or
other resources creating dns records and
much more so various services under this
are vpc that stands for virtual private
cloud you have cloud load balancing
cloud armor cloud cdn you have cloud
interconnect dns and network service
tiers when we talk about the big data
service this allows us to process and
query big data in cloud
now various services under these are as
follows you have bigquery cloud cloud
data proc cloud composer cloud data lab
cloud data prep cloud pub sub which is
publish and subscribing system you have
cloud data studio now you also have the
developer tools and developer tools
service includes tools related to
development of an application now
various services under these are as
follows that is you have cloud sdk
software development kit you have
deployment manager cloud source
repositories and cloud test lab when we
talk about identity and security which
is one of the primary concerns for any
organization or any user who would be
interested in using a cloud platform
google cloud really has taken care of
this
so when you talk about identity and
security domain this deals with security
services now various services here
are cloud identity you have identity and
access management that is cloud iam you
have identity aware proxies you have
cloud data loss prevention api
security key enforcement key management
service and many more
you also have cloud services which are
related to internet of things so very
much would be used by organizations who
would be working on iot devices or the
data generated by these devices so
various services here
are cloud iot core you have edge tpu and
cloud iot also when we talk about cloud
ai that is artificial intelligence this
comprises of services related to machine
learning and much more so you have cloud
auto ml
cloud tpu cloud machine learning engine
job discovery
dialog flow enterprise natural language
cloud text to speech and much more
if you would be interested in services
related to api platform then there are
different services under this category
or this domain so you have maps platform
you have apg api platform monetization
developer portal analytics that is api
analytics abg sense cloud endpoints and
service infrastructure
so these are some of the listing of
services under each cloud platform
domain
now let's look at ferrero use case and
let's also understand what was done here
so ferrero is one of the famous
chocolate and ranks third among
worldwide chocolate and confectionary
producers it was found in
1946 in italy i'm sure you would have
seen the ferrero chocolates when you
would have gone out to buy some
chocolates so the challenges here was
that federal as we know is sold in every
supermarket and is known for its quality
once the business grew some issues arose
right and that's what happens when the
business grows you have issues popping
up which could be related to the volume
of data the speed with which the data is
getting generated the variety of data
and also looking at your platforms which
support different dynamic applications
or your scalability requirements
performance requirements and so on
so it needed data storage processing and
analysis system for a wide customer
database
there was a huge gap between the company
and the people who bought its goods
because the company relied on data given
sales outlets now that's one of the
challenge
ferro wanted to create a digital
ecosystem where there was a point of
contact with its customers and also a
foundation for an innovative data-driven
marketing strategy what was the solution
here so one of the service of cloud
platforms or google cloud platform is
bigquery and this was an answer to
ferraro's challenges since it was
capable of hyper fast and efficient data
analysis as a solution
now as i mentioned bigquery is a data
warehouse which allows you to store
structured data now this could directly
be used as a service where you could
store in any amount of data and you
would not be paying for storage so there
are different pricing models
and
for data
up to one terabytes you would not be
charged anything
and if you would be accessing the data
that is reading the data or processing
the data from bigquery that's where the
pricing model kicks in
now using google cloud's bigquery
business analysts of federal were able
to store and analyze massive data sets
in a very reliable fast and affordable
manner
consumer behavior and sales pattern data
reports were easy to build and automate
and the analysis also followed federer
to adopt
advertising across various marketing
channels to serve the customer needs in
a better way what was the result
they could divide their database into
real-time actionable consumer clusters
to generate more accurate user profiles
ferro was also able to personalize its
marketing strategies to match the user
needs
now google cloud platform completely
tailored the website mobile content and
advertising
and created a very cost effective media
by strategy
now these were some basics on google
cloud now as i said you can always find
a lot of details about pricing about
services
and also all the services are accessible
in your free trial account now let me
just walk you through here so one is
you could always find details on
documentation on each of these services
so if i would click on getting started
you have quick start which basically
shows you short tutorials
you have trainings and you have also
certifications now if we click on quick
start
now that takes me to this page which
shows me
quick starts
or if you would want to understand about
different projects
if you would want to look into the
documentation of creating a linux
virtual machine or storing a file and
sharing it deploying a container docker
container image and so on so you have a
lot of quick starts here you can also
look at cloud minute
on the same page on the right side you
have docs and once you click on that it
takes you to these
links now this shows you build solutions
which shows your top use cases best
practices all the solutions it's always
good to learn from these use cases which
are available and here you have
different feature products and all the
different services
which google cloud offers now you can
click on featured products
and that basically shows you a list of
these products now here we have all the
solutions which you can look at
architecture database enterprise level
big data and analysis gaming related
internet of things and so on now if you
go down here it shows you featured
products and that shows you
some of the important products such as
compute engine which is belonging to the
compute domain you have cloud run you
have anthers which is for migration
and basically cloud
adoption
when organizations would want to move
from on-premise to cloud-based solutions
you have vision ai you have cloud
storage now that basically allows you to
store any kind of data whether that's an
object so this is acting as an object
storage you have cloud sql which is
basically a ready to use
service where you would be using mysql
postgres or any other sql server
database services you have bigquery
which is a data warehouse which
basically allows you to store your
structured data
and then you have your ai and machine
learning related products so you have
auto ml vision ai video ai text to
speech space to text and so on
now you also have different platform
accelerators which can be used and in
any of these cases for example if i
would click on compute engine which is a
featured product from google cloud now
that shows you
basically your quick starts
using your linux machines how to guides
which tells you completely working on a
vm instance
or working on storage working on
persistent disks and so on and it shows
you the documentation here now you also
have products and pricing option which
you can see for gcp pricing and you
could straight away go to the pricing
you could be looking at solutions which
talks about infrastructure modernization
now this is something which
organizations are interested in when
they would want to move from their
on-premise solution to your google cloud
now here i can say for example i click
on infrastructure modernization you can
always find some case studies what are
the different solutions we have here
right when you talk about google cloud
so you can always click on see solutions
and you can look at vm migration or sap
cloud right why google cloud what it can
be used for vmware as a service or hpc
that is high performance computing and
about these services we will learn in
detail later
now i can go back on the same page where
i was clicking on the services so you
have quick starts you have how to guides
you have deep understanding of different
concepts
right and here if i click on all how to
guides so that shows me what are the
different ways in which you can work
with compute engine and working with
different instances although it's quite
exhaustive content but then if you
follow steadily then you can learn a lot
about google cloud
now here i can just go back so this is
just giving you some idea on the
different products which are available
from google cloud looking into different
sections finding right documentation
here right and you can always look into
each one of these in detail for each
product which google cloud offers
now
if we scroll down we could see all the
options or all the domains which we see
here right let me just go back because
we got into solutions now we have quick
starts right
and then you can basically scroll all
the way down to look at cloud sdk which
can be set up on your windows machine
like i have set it up on my windows
machine
plus when you use google console you
have a gui which i'll show you in couple
of minutes and also a cloud shell where
you can use your command line options to
work with google cloud platform you have
cloud console which is nothing but your
gui to access your resources
now you can also look at in-depth
tutorials pricing and you have different
other options so let's just click on
pricing here and then we have
your price list which basically gives
you details of different services what
are available
and what are the services or what are
the prices so for example if i click on
compute engine right and this shows me
the pricing aspect of compute engine
which belongs to compute domain and here
you can see you have vm instance pricing
you have networking pricing sole tenant
nodes which are specific to particular
organizations or if organizations would
want to have dedicated nodes you have
gpu based pricing right so general
processing units you have disk and image
pricing and you can click on any of the
links and you can see pricing which also
shows you your different kind of machine
types so here you have different kind of
machine types which says n1 n2 n2d e2
you have memory optimized machine types
you have compute optimized you have
premium images
and you can basically look at all the
categories you can look at disk pricing
which involves your persistent disk
pricing for ssds or sdds what are the
kind of images what are the different
network services right and you can
always look at
your machine types you can choose a
particular region right there is the
concept of region and availability zones
here and as per region you could look at
the prices
you can also look at standard prices you
could be looking for what are the free
tier machines if i'm specifically
looking for vm instance pricing i can
click on this one and that takes me to
the vm instance pricing what is the
billing module what is the instance up
time what is the resource-based pricing
and then you can also look at different
kind of discounts such as sustained use
discounts committed use discounts
discounts for preemptable vm instances
and so on and this is how you can be
looking at pricing for all different
resources and you can choose the
resource which you are interested in and
then look for the pricing benchmarks
reservations if you would want to use
and you would want to benefit if you
would want to look at what are the
quotas and limits and so on so please
explore this link and you can find lot
of information when it comes to
technical options looking at different
google cloud products which we briefly
discussed when it comes to domains
and what each product can be used for
you can always come back to the main
page where i was showing you different
services we went into pricing straight
away right now you can always come back
to this page
on
yourcloud.google.com and then you have
your solutions
which talks about different products
right and you can click on these or you
can look into technical documentation so
this talks about your different featured
solutions infrastructure solutions you
have data center migration related and
so on so i could be talking more and
more about google cloud platform it's a
ocean it's a huge chunk of different
services for different organizational
requirements so look into this link
and also what you can do is create a
account on gmail i mean you could create
a free account or you could go to
cloud.google.com
and then you could create a free account
like i have created here and i can just
click on console now that's my gui or
google cloud console which basically
allows me to work with google cloud now
there are a lot of options here by
default when you create an account now
in my case on the top it says it's a
free trial account i have 300 credit and
out of that 251 dollars is left and 237
days out of a year are left for my
account now here i can basically see the
project right and by default we can
create a project or by default there is
a project existing for any user so when
you log in it creates a particular
project and you could create a new
project and project would be to dedicate
your different services or different
resources per different project so this
is your dashboard which basically shows
your project which shows you a project
number and a project id which is always
unique now you can click on this and
this if you would want you can hide this
information you can also look into the
documentation part of it then it shows
you the different services or a
graphical information of services which
you might have used in past
so you have compute engine which shows
you how much percentage of cpu was used
you can always go to compute engine as a
service you can look at your google
route platform status and look at the
google cloud status now this is billing
now since this shows me the billing
period for april month and i can always
look at detailed charges i can look at
reporting i can look at different apis
which google offers
and
for your different kind of work you can
always go to the api overview or the api
link and enable or disable any api now
once you enable or disable any api then
you can use that so you have new section
you have documentation and you have
getting started guides which tells you
how to work or enable different apis if
you would want to deploy a pre-built
solution add dynamic logging monitoring
errors deploying a hello world app and
so on now this is your dashboard i can
click on activity and that would show me
what kind of activity i would have done
in my cloud platform i can always choose
the kind of activities
by saying activity type i can choose the
resources now it shows me that i created
some vm instances i deleted them i
updated some metadata i basically worked
on instances i changed some firewall
rules here i have then also worked on
some other services or api so i created
some buckets which is for object storage
and again i have been working with some
instances and creating some firewall
rules
here i have granted some permissions i
am setting up a policy right so this
activity gives me a history of what
things i have done over the past couple
of months
while working on google cloud platform
now
on the top left corner you have the
hamburger menu which you can click on
this so that's your navigation menu and
when you click on this this shows you
home it takes you to the marketplace it
specifically takes you to billing you
can always look at apis and services so
here in api services i can pretty much
go to a dashboard and i can see a report
on the traffic or errors or latency and
the kind of apis which are available so
you have compute engine api you have
bigquery api bigquery data transfer api
bigquery storage cloud data proc so
these are some of the apis or services
i've used in past might be i was
evaluating a product might be i was
using a particular product so you have
whenever you would want to use a
particular service from google cloud
platform you would be enabling these
apis so here we see some apis for data
proc you have
logging monitoring you have resource
manager api you have cloud sql which
allows you to directly use mysql or
postgres you have cloud storage right
and so many apis
so if i would want to enable a
particular api which is not right now
required but then it's good to know you
can always click on this one you can
search for an api so for example if i
would say data proc right and that shows
me the cloud data proc api which manages
hadoop based clusters and jobs on google
cloud platform so i can spin up a hadoop
cluster and i can start running some
jobs on a hadoop cluster on demand and
as i am done with it i can just get rid
of it so this is an api which i would
have to enable
and then for every particular service
you also have an admin api which you
would enable
now going back so coming out from this
api library i got into api and services
now there is
you can look into the library you can
look at credentials and you can also
look at
different time intervals for which you
can see the usage of your different apis
now going back to the menu you have
support
wherein you can always reach out to the
google support team if you are
using a paid version even with free
trial you can try to reach out and you
will find someone to help but it is
always good when you have a billing
cycle reaching out the customer care you
have identity access management in admin
and this is required when you are
working with different apis or services
when you would want to have relevant
access you have getting started you have
security related options you have anthos
which is mainly for migration now here
you can look at your different domains
such as which we discussed so you have
compute and in compute you have
different services so you have app
engine you have compute engine
kubernetes you have cloud functions and
cloud run you can look into the storage
aspect which shows you big table which
is usually and mainly for your
unstructured data
bigtable which is something which gave
rise to popular nosql databases like
hbase and cassandra you have data store
which can be used you have firestore
file store storage which can be used to
put in data of any kinds you have sql
for structured data you have spanner as
a service you have memory store and you
have data transfer
now when it comes to the networking
domain you have all these services such
as vpc virtual private network network
related services for your load balancing
for using a cloud-based dns or cloud
defined network you have hybrid
connectivity network service tiers
security and intelligence
then you have other options for your
operations which can be used and here
you have different other tools which can
be used such as cloud build you have
cloud tasks containers registry
deployment manager and many more
big data specific you have the services
here so you have data proc which can be
used to spin up your clusters you have
published subscribe messaging system
such as now kafka which you might have
heard of originates its idea from here
so pub sub you have data flow you have
iot core bigquery which is a data
warehouse package or data warehousing
solution from google cloud
now then you have your artificial
intelligence related services and other
google solutions
so you can always find a huge list of
services or you can say at high level
solutions offered by google cloud and we
can use these to basically test some of
the solutions use them and work on them
so i'll give you a quick demo on
different services which can be used
here from your google cloud platform now
this is your google cloud platform and
this is your console now this also gives
you a cloud shell which can be activated
so that you can work from command line
and you can always find a lot of
documentation on that so you can also
set up your cloud shell that is sdk on
your windows machine and if you have set
it up then basically you could be doing
something like gcloud right if the cloud
has been set up so in my case
i had set up the cloud sdk and basically
i can get into that
by looking at what path i have set up so
cloud sdk and then i can be using it
from my windows machine as per my
comfort i can also activate the cloud
shell here which will basically open up
a terminal and at any point of time you
can open up this one cloud shell in a
different window it is preparing the
cloud shell where it will by default set
up your project it will set up the
metadata and now i am logged into my
google cloud account from command line
and here i can basically use gcloud
right and that basically shows you the
different options which are available
which you can be using so if you would
want to use a particular service you can
also try giving a help and that shows
you how do you manage your google cloud
platform right so you have different
options for billing to work with your
different services
and basically you could be working on
google cloud using this cloud shell from
your command line
usually for people who are learning
google cloud in the beginning it is
always good to go for console and use
your different services from here in an
easier way but as i said you can always
use the command line for example if i
would just go ahead and type gcloud
create
instances
and that will directly take me to the
cloud console documentation which shows
you different options which you can use
to work with instances so i could do a
gcloud compute instances create and then
i can give my instance name and so on
and i'll show you some examples on that
so you can be using your cloud console
right that is your cloud shell and you
can straight away start working from
command line however i would suggest
using console in the beginning and when
you are well experienced then you can
start using cloud shell to do things
from command line and when you are fully
experienced you can always switch and
certain things are usually useful or
easier when done from command line and
some are easier when you do it from the
console and you can use any one of these
options now we can go to google cloud
console now as of now i can close this
one i still have my cloud shell open if
i would want to look into it i can click
on this one and i can straight away go
to compute engine where i would want to
work on creating some instances on
google cloud platform using the compute
engine service and then basically
connecting to those instances and
basically trying out some basic things
so you can click on vm instances
and then once this comes up i can always
create some instances now if you see
here i have some instances already
created right and i can continue working
on those i can create new instances i
can use different options while creating
instances and i'll show you that in a
demo in quick seconds
so let's have a quick demo on setting up
gcp instances now before that let's have
a quick recap so when you talk about
instance or a virtual machine it is
hosted on google's infrastructure right
and you can create your google cloud
instance using this google cloud console
that is by clicking on this and then
going to compute engine and clicking on
vm instances now you can also do that
from google cloud command line tool that
is cloud shell and you can be doing that
using compute engine api
so compute engine instances can run the
public images for linux or windows
servers
that google provides you also have
option of creating or using custom
images that you can create and import
from your existing systems you can
deploy docker containers which are
automatically launched on instance
running containers optimized os now when
you talk about instances and projects
always remember that in each instance
belongs to a google cloud console
project and a project can have one or
more instances
when you talk about instances and
storage options each instance has a
small boot persistent disk which i will
show you in further screens
that contains the os you can add more
storage space if needed and when you
talk about instances and network a
project can have up to five vpc networks
so vpc network is virtual private
networks wherein you can virtual private
cloud networks where you can have your
resources within your own subnet
and each instance belongs to one vpc
network
now instances in same network can
communicate with each other through
local area network protocol
an instance uses internet to communicate
within any machine so that could be
virtual physical or outside its own
network when you talk about instances
and containers you should remember that
compute engine instances support a
declarative method for launching your
application using containers
now you can create a vm instance or a vm
instance template
you can provide a docker image and
launch the configuration
so there are different ways in which you
can create these instances and once you
create these instances you can say for
example you are creating a linux
instance you can associate ssh keys with
your google account or your g suite
account and then manage your admin
non-admin access to the instance using
im roles if you connect to your instance
using gcloud or ssh from console which
we will see later compute engine can
generate ssh keys for you and apply that
to your google cloud or g suite account
now what we can do is we can see how we
can create your google cloud instances
from your console or from the command
line let's have a look in creating
instances using gcp console now that we
have learned on some basics of google
cloud platform what are the different
services what are different domains
basically looking at your google cloud
console or even cloud shell
let's go ahead and create some vm
instances now that's from your compute
engine service and let's try connecting
to these instances and see how this
works let's also see what are the
different options which are available
when you would want to create the
virtual machine instances here so when
you click on your drop down from the top
left and choose
compute engine so it brings you to this
page so i can show that again so you can
click on compute engine click on vm
instances and that basically brings you
to this page now here it tells you
compute engine lets you use virtual
machines that run on google's
infrastructure so we can create micro
vms or large instances running different
distributions of linux or windows using
standard images that is public images
and you can also have your own image so
let's create a vm instance by clicking
on create
now that's basically helping me to
create an instance here so it shows me
the instance name i can give it
something so let me say c1 now i can add
labels so what is label it basically
allows you to organize your project add
arbitrary labels as key value pairs to
your resources this so this is basically
categorizing your labels and projects if
you have multiple projects now remember
if you have your cloud console and if
you have created your free trial account
it will allow you to do these things if
not you may have to go back to the
billing section and see if the billing
is enabled which also means that when
you are creating your google cloud
account it will ask you to key in your
credit card details but they do not
charge anything or they might charge
might be one dollar or one rupee
depending on your location and that's
also refunded but that's just to verify
your card now once i've given the name i
can choose a region so i would basically
choose europe since i'm in europe i
would be clicking on europe west 3 and
here i can choose an availability zone
availability zone is basically to make
your services
or instances or any other resources
highly available so you can choose one
of the availability zones now i would
choose save s3 now this one we can
scroll down and here it says machine
configurations you have general purpose
machines you have memory optimized
machines which is m1 series and you can
always go back to the google cloud page
and see
what a particular kind of machine
specializes in so i would click on
general's purpose and in general purpose
you have different categories so you
have n1 which is powered by intel
skylake cpu platform or you have e2
which is cpu platform selected selection
based on availability so let's have n1
selected now this one shows me the
machine type and if you are using your
free tier account then you can start
with collecting a micro machine which is
one virtual cpu core you can go for a g1
small which is one virtual cpu core and
1.7 gb ram you can even go up to a
high-end machine and then
you can basically see if you are using a
free account how many of these machines
you can use if i would be selecting
eight virtual cpu cores and 32 gigabyte
of memory then it would allow me to
create at least two instances by this
configuration we will use n1 standard
which is one virtual cpu core 3.75 gb
memory now then we can also deploy a
container image to this vm instance if
you would be interested in deploying a
container image let's not get into that
right now
here it shows you the boot disk and it
shows you dbng dbn gnu 9 linux 9. what i
would do is i can go for this
distribution or i can choose a linux
distribution of my choice so here you
have public images you have custom
images you also have snapshots if you
have created backup of your previous
images
here i can choose for example ubuntu and
then i can choose a particular version
so let's go for ubuntu 18.04 you can go
for the latest one also 18.04 would be
good enough
and here it tells me what is the boot
disk so you have ssds or you have
standard persistent disks now ssds are
little expensive in comparison to your
standard persistent disks or your sdds
but then ssds are faster so as of now we
can choose standard persistent disk as
it is and we can let the gigabyte be 10
now depending on your requirement you
can increase this you can even add disks
later that's not a problem click on
select now here i have access scopes so
here i will say allow default access you
can also set access for each api or you
can give full access to all cloud apis
so that based on your requirement you
can any time change later also we will
also say allow http traffic and we can
also choose allow https traffic that
basically allows me to access this
machine or services which are http based
accessible from this machine now i can
just click on create however it would be
good to basically enable connectivity to
this machine now we can do that in
different ways one is when you bring up
your machine it will have an ssh access
which you can log in from the cloud
platform here itself or what you can do
is you can create a private and a public
key using some software's like putty or
putty gen so for example if you do not
have that on your machine you can
download you can just type in download
putty that takes you to the putty.org
page and here you can click on download
putty and scroll down which shows you
for your 64-bit machine which i have in
my case you can download putty.exe which
is basically your ssh and telnet client
to connect to your machines you can also
use putty gen which will be allowing you
to create a private and a public key
which i have done in my case let me show
you how so what you can do is you can go
to puttygen to begin with and here you
can click on generate now then to have
this key generated just move your cursor
on the top here in the empty space and
that creates your key you can give it a
name so for example let's give a
username i would give
hdu now i can give a password for this
one so let me give a simple password
and what i can also do is i can copy
this public key from here and for my
later usage i can just keep it in my
notepad file which i can use later and
i'll show you when
so now we can save this private key and
this will basically allow me to save my
private key i can choose desktop and i
can give it a name so let's say
new key
new key and that will be getting saved
in a dot ppk file so let's save it and
that's done so we also have our public
key and we have saved our private key
now we know that when you would want to
connect using ssh you need your private
keys to the client and public key also
has to be existing so let's take this
public key so let's do a control a i'm
going to copy this and i'm going to come
back to my google cloud console and here
you can click on security so you can
click on the security tab here
scroll down
and just give your public key once you
give that it resolves and shows you the
name and this is good enough so that i
can use my ssh client to connect to this
machine i can click on create and this
will basically create my vm instance it
will take some time and then your
instance will have an internal ip which
will show up here
external ip and it will also show you
options to connect to these machines so
this is my internal ip this is my
external ip which i can use to connect
from a client i can easily connect from
the option here which says ssh and i can
say open in a browser window i can even
open this in a custom port i can look at
the gcloud command which you can give
from cloud shell or you can use another
ssh so let's first do a open in browser
window and let's see if this connects so
we can easily connect to our instance in
the ubuntu 18 instance which i just set
up here easily in couple of seconds now
this is trying to establish a connection
using your ssh keys
and when you do that it also basically
brings up this web browser so i'm
already connected it shows my username
which is my cloud account username and i
have been connected to this machine here
using ssh it did not ask me for any
password
and basically now i can just check what
do i have in my linux file system right
and i can anytime login as root by doing
a sudo su for example let's try
installing a package and i can say
apt-get install vim
or apt-get install wget
or apt-get install
open ssh and all these packages are
already existing so not an issue now i
can start using this instance i can just
look at the disk what is available okay
now we gave around 10 gigabyte out of
which we see 8.3 gigabyte here
for the dev sda1 and then 1.8 gigabyte
available and you can continue using
this machine this was the easiest way of
connecting to a vm instance using ssh
now what we can also do is i can just
leave this and i will now try to connect
using an external ssh client right and
here you can copy the public ip so when
you want to connect to an instance you
will have to get the public ip also
remember that if you select and stop
this machine which will stop your
billing counter and if you start it
again the internal ip will remain same
but the external ip is the one which
will change
i can obviously select this machine
anytime and i can do a cleanup and i can
delete it
i can do a start of the machine if it is
stopped and i can even import the
virtual machine to be used later so
there are different options which you
can always use
so this is my instance and if you would
want to look at the details click on
this one c1 and that should basically
allow you to look at the details so it
shows you what is the instance id what
is the machine type is it reservation
specific what is the cpu platform what's
the zone and all the other details
at any point of time if you would want
to edit you can always click on edit and
you can change the details as you need
now you can also look at the equivalent
rest command to basically use the rest
api to connect to this instance for now
i have copied the public ip and i would
want to connect it using putty so let's
go in here and let's give it the host
name so i can give ubuntu i can give my
ip address so that's in my session now i
will click on ssh i would go into
authentication i'll click on browse and
this is where i need to choose the ppk
file so this is the one which we created
new key let's select this
and then i can come back to session i
can even save this and i can call it as
my instance one
let's save it and you can create any
number of instances so you see i have
created different instances here for my
google cloud or amazon related instances
and i can click on open it says the
service host key is not cached in the
registry that's fine just click on yes
and basically it says
no authentication method supported now
this could be because we have not
enabled your ssh access so let's look at
that so now let's see if we were trying
to connect using putty what was the
issue here so if i go back to my
putty select my instance load it it says
port 22 i am giving the username which
is ubuntu or sorry that's the wrong
username we gave and that might be the
reason we had set up the user ssdu so
let's save this again and now let's try
connecting to this one and it asks for
my password and you are able to connect
this right now if there was any other
issue related to network connectivity
then we could look at the rules the
inbound and outbound rules which allow
us to look into the machine now we are
connected to our machine here using hdu
user i can log in as root and i can
continue working
so not only from the ssh within the
cloud console but you can use an
external ssh client and connect to your
machine so this is your ubuntu machine
and we can basically look at the space
and that basically confirms we are
connecting to the same machine which
shows 8.3 gigabytes here and 1.8
gigabytes here which we were seeing from
the ssh in the browser now let's close
this and let's go back to our instance
page now here you can always look at the
network details and this will show you
your different kind of rules that is
ingress or egress rules which basically
allows to connect to this machine from
an external network or for this machine
to connect to an external network so
here we have different firewall rules
which shows default allow http that's
your ingress rule and it tells you apply
to all it shows me what are the ip
ranges where i can specifically give the
ipf my machine it shows the protocols it
shows what are the different ports which
you have used for these services for
example rdp or ssh which shows 22 you
have icmp http and https now anytime if
you would want to make a change to these
rules that can be done by going into
your network details and say for example
you would want to work on firewall rules
so we have these
firewall rules here you can click on
this one so right now we are looking
into the network domain and we are
looking into vpc network right and this
shows me what are the different rules we
have now if i would want to create a
different firewall rule for a different
protocol
i can always click on create firewall
rule i can give it a name okay i can say
what if you would want to turn on the
firewall logs you can basically say what
is the kind of traffic so ingress
applies to incoming traffic and egress
applies to outgoing traffic and you can
then basically choose what are the ip
ranges from where you want that
connection to be coming in or to going
out you can choose a particular protocol
you can give a protocol
here with comma separated values and you
can create a firewall rule so this might
be required depending on the services
which you are running wherein you might
want to enable your access to your
machine from an external service or to
an external service so you can always go
to network details from here you can
then go into firewall rules create a
firewall rule apply that to your
instance and restart your instance so as
of now we don't need to create any
network details here because my ingress
or egress rules are already available
right now i can basically then have my
instance stopped and removed so i can
just do a stop or since this is running
the ideal wave would be to do a stop i
could also do a reset now what does
reset do reset does not basically delete
the machine what it does is it does a
clean up of the machine and it brings it
to the initial state so sometimes we
might have installed certain things on
our machine we would want to clean them
up and at that time reset can be useful
i can basically click on delete right
and i can select this and i can do a
cleanup and this is good always when you
are using a free trial account try to
use different services play around with
them and then you can clean up so that
you do not waste your free billing
credit right and you can use it for
meaningful stuff
now i have clicked on delete and within
few seconds my instance which i had
created will be deleted also to remember
is if you are creating multiple
instances
then you can connect from one machine to
other machine using ssh by using the
private file so for that we can learn in
detail later so this is just a simple
example of using your compute engine
creating your instances connecting to it
from an internal ssh or from an external
ssh client such as putty where you have
already created your private and public
keys
now i can click on the browser here and
then i can basically come out and i can
basically be looking into any particular
service so we just looked into compute
engine right you have different other
options you have instance groups you
have instance templates for example
let's click on instance templates here
and that basically shows you that you
don't have any instance template and
this basically facilitates say for
example you are working as an admin and
you would want to create an instance
template so that using that you can
describe a vm instance and then you can
basically use this template to create
different instances
you can go for sole tenant notes you can
look for machine images you can also
look at your disks you can create a
snapshots and you can look at different
options here now let's come back here
and let's click on home and that should
take you back to your home page which
basically shows you if a particular api
which you have used recently which shows
me in the graph here
so i can go to the api's overview right
and that basically shows me if there
were any errors if i was using the
compute engine api to basically create a
vm instance and that's why we were
seeing some spike in the graph
so this is a quick demo of using your
compute engine service provided by
google cloud wherein you can create vm
instances and use those vm instances for
your application installation
for any other purpose
now that we have seen how you use your
cloud console to create an instance and
also clean it up
let's also understand how you can do
using your command line options and
let's see what it takes or what are the
different commands which you can use to
create your instances
now you can always when when you're
creating an instance you can use compute
engine which provisions resources to
start the instance so instance basically
has different states which we can see
when we are creating the instance
so you basically start the instance
instance moves into staging that is
prepared for your first boot
finally it boots up and then it moves
into running so when you look at instant
states which we will create instance in
c
it will basically have different states
such as provisioning where resources are
being allocated for instance but
instance is not yet running then it goes
into staging where resources have been
acquired an instance is being prepared
for your first boot then instance
is booting up and running and if you are
stopping an instance it goes into being
stop status and it would be moved to the
terminated option you can also do a
repairing of instance and finally you
can terminate your instance or clean it
up by stopping and then deleting it
now when you say stopping and resetting
an instance you can stop the instance as
i showed earlier if you no longer need
it but if you need for future use you
can just use the reset option which will
basically wipe the contents of instance
or any application state and then
finally you can stop it and have it
terminated now when you would want to do
that using your cloud console or we have
seen the options now let's also see from
the command line tool how you can do it
so here i have the cloud shell which i
brought up from here and i basically
opened it in a new window so command
line tool enables you to easily manage
your compute engine resources in a
friendlier format than using your
compute engine api now gcloud which is
part of cloud sdk is the main command
here and then you can always auto
complete the different options here so
when you would want to create or work on
gcloud you can just type in gcloud here
and then for example i could just say
help to see different options of gcloud
which will show me different options
which you can use here now we would be
interested in compute instances so i
could also do a g cloud
compute
compute
instances and then i can basically say
create and then i can do a help now that
should show me different options which
work with gcloud compute instances
create command which is expecting an
instance name
so your google cloud sdk
which we can set up on our windows
machine or even on your linux machine is
set of tools that
helps you to manage resources and
applications hosted on your gcp that is
your google cloud platform now here you
have options such as gcloud which i i'm
showing you right now you have gsutil
and then you have bq so that also can be
used so you can set up a google cloud
compute if using gcloud
now what we can do is
if we are setting up our sdk on our
windows machine then we would have to do
a gcloud init which basically
initializes
your configurations for g cloud
now here we are using a cloud shell
which was started from the console and
we don't have to basically give your
gcloud init command because it's already
initialized now you can always look at
your default zone you can look at your
region what is being used all those
things are coming from the metadata
which is being used so for example i
could be looking at the metadata for my
particular project by just doing a g
cloud and then i can say compute
and i would be interested in project
info
so i can just do a project minus info
and then i can do it describe
and then i need my project id so i can
say minus minus project and i can get my
project id from here so you can click on
this one and that's my project id so i
can click on this one
and here i can just do a right click and
if it does not paste then you can do a
ctrl v
and then i can try to look at my project
info so this basically will give me the
metadata which is by default set
and we can always look at what are the
regions or what is the zone which has
been set
so if it has been set so i'm looking at
my details it is showing me my ssh keys
and then it can be using your default
region
and your default available zones it also
shows my username and other details so
this is basically to look at the
metadata which is available now at any
point of time i can basically say add
metadata i can basically choose metadata
option and i can say my default region
should be europe which i was choosing
earlier so i can just bring up this
command again and what i can do is i can
say here where i have gcloud compute
project info where i did it described
earlier now what i could also do is i
can just say add metadata
and then i can specify what is the
metadata i would be interested in adding
i can then say google compute
default
region
and then i can basically give a region
for example europe
and then i can say west 3
and if you are not well experienced you
can always do it from console or you can
be doing it from here so i'm giving
google cloud compute google compute
default region then i can also give a
google compute default zone
and then i can pass in a value for
default zone so i can say europe
west 3
and then basically i can give an
availability zone so if
it is basically giving me some error
where i am trying to pass in these
values so i can just give it this way
and then it basically says that if you
can look into particular help to see
what is the command which you would have
to do now i can basically do a g cloud
init here initial configuration and this
basically says that it is initializing
my
default configuration it says
reinitialize this configuration from
cloud shell
you want to create a new configuration
so if i had updated my
metadata
then basically i could just do a cloud
init
and i could be re-initializing my
default configuration or properties
which i have passed in so as of now i
will not activate or change the default
region let's go for a simple way in
which you can create your compute engine
so for example i'll just say one
and it is re-initializing it asks me
what is the user name
and let's select that it says what is
the project
and let's select that
and do you want to configure a default
compute region and zone right and i will
just say yes
and basically then it shows me different
options which we have here
so there are too many options here and
then here we were interested in
europe west 3 so let's choose 21
right and then that basically allows me
to choose my region and my zone so it
also gives you some specification so it
says your project default compute zone
has been set to europe s3 a you can
change it by running gcloud config set
and you can give a compute zone right so
i can always give these commands i can
get help information here so i can just
say gcloud config set and i can be
specifying the compute zone so i can say
compute slash zone and i can give a zone
i can say compute slash region and i can
give a region name if i would want to do
it or the easier way is like what i did
right now so you can basically do a
command gcloud in it and then basically
it allows you to change your
configuration or set
default things here you cannot all the
times you can say gcloud config unset
to basically remove a compute zone or a
compute region now there are different
ways so if you were working on a linux
machine you could always
use an export command something like
this so you could do export compute
sorry cloud
sdk
and then you can say compute underscore
zone
and then give your zone name or compute
underscore region and give your region
or you could add it in your bash rc file
right now that is when you have your
cloud sdk setup on your linux machine or
on windows machine and you would want to
specifically set a zone and a region for
all your compute related resources so we
don't need to do that the default
settings are already given here right
and what we can do is we can start by
quickly looking into
gcloud compute instances options so i
can say gcloud compute instances
and then i can just do a list at any
point of time if you would need help you
can just do a gcloud compute and then
say minus minus help or i could just do
a gcloud compute and that shows me
different options which i have here from
which i use instances
i can always type instances and again
hit enter and it shows me different
options what you would want to do so i
can initially just type list which
should show me what are the list
or what are the instances available and
as of now we don't have any instances i
can always do a list and then i can
specify minus minus format and then try
to get the information in a json format
or ml or minus minus format text
so you can always do a list you can do a
filter so there are different options
with your list and you can you can try
doing a help here and that basically
shows you what are the options so for
example if i do a help and it shows me
with list what are the things you can do
so you can give a name you can give a
regular expression you can say in
particular zone you can use a minus
filter so there are different commands
which are available and you can always
find all those options here as i showed
you earlier so now what we would be
interested in is basically going for
your compute instances i can always do a
ssh and i can create an instance
i can add and remove metadata right for
my instances
by giving a particular zone by giving a
particular region and if you would want
to do that now here what we can do is we
can basically create an instance by just
giving a name to that particular
instance
and we can then go back to our console
and see what has it done so i can say
here create so that's an option let's
see what does the create do so it says
okay you are giving a create option but
you would have to give a name
so let's say
let's call it e1 and that will be the
name of my instance and this one is an
easy command from your cloud shell which
basically creates an instance you see
the zone which has been set it is the
standard machine type it is not
preemptable it has an internal ip and it
has an external ip
now i have created an instance and here
i can just go back and then i can just
do a refresh on this page and that
already shows me the instance which i
have created and then you can use the
same method to connect to it using an
ssh so i have an instance created from
my cloud shell
and what i can do is i can basically
look into instances and see what are the
different options with instance so if we
did a create
right you have an option delete
we did a create you have an option
delete you can be then deleting the
instance from the command line or you
can use other options so you can do a
list
you can do a stop
you can start so i can basically do a
stop and let's say even let's go ahead
and do a stop commands are pretty easy
here to remember or you can always use
the help option and now i'm trying to
stop the instance and then basically i
can go ahead and delete it so this is a
simple way where i created a instance
from the command line or from the
console which i showed earlier and
similarly you can be working with other
options so now i've created stop the
instance let's do a listing to see
if my instance shows up it shows up
right and it says the status is
terminated so you have stopped it
it's in the terminated status and now
what i can do is i can go ahead and
delete it
so it says this will be lost are you
sure you would want to continue just say
yes and that should take care of
deleting your instance
so this is a quick demo on creating your
instance we have already seen how you
can connect to these instances using ssh
now that we have created instances let's
also see how to use google cloud's
storage
service which can be used to load data
or upload data so for this we will have
to look into your google cloud storage
options and here you can look in cloud
storage so let's go back here on the top
which shows me different services which
we have here and let's look into storage
so this one shows me your storage option
now you can click on browser and that
basically shows me your storage browser
which shows me on the top you have
options for
creating a bucket
now google cloud storage allows you to
store any kind of data here
the easiest and the simplest way would
be by using cloud console although you
can again use cloud shell and in that
you can use your gsutil command
and gsutil basically has different
options where you can be
using say for example i would want to
work on buckets so i can be using mb and
then i can use my command line option to
create buckets i can put in data there i
can browse it and i can access the data
from command line so let's create a
bucket here
let's click on this let's give it a name
so let's say my
data important that's the name
now i can click on continue straight
away i can look into all of these
options if i'm interested in
so you can basically be looking at your
monthly cost estimate in the beginning
now i can click on continue or you can
say choose where to store your data and
this one shows you different options so
you have region specific
so let's also give the bucket name with
all lower case that's what is required
yeah so coming back to the location type
you can choose multi-region which
basically allows high availability so
your bucket or your storage option will
be accessible across regions
you can also give dual region and high
availability and low latency across two
regions i can also say region specific
so for our use case we can just give
region specific which can keep our cost
low but in business use cases you would
be going for multi region
now here you have location and i would
again go for say europe and let's choose
europe west 3 frankfurt it is always a
good practice that when you create your
instances when you create your storage
or you use different services try to
have a geographical region chosen and
then you would try to put things or your
services within the particular region
within a particular zone unless you
would want to make it
accessible and available across regions
now i can then choose a default storage
class so when you say default storage
class there are different storage class
and each one is for a different use case
so you have standard which is best for
short-term storage and frequently
accessed data you have near line so this
is basically best for backups and data
access less than once a month you can
also have cold lines so these are
basically like your cold storage or
freezing storage which you might have
heard generically as terms so you can
choose one of these storage classes
depending on what will be the use case
for this particular storage bucket so
let it be standard now how to control
access to objects so you can basically
say specify access to individual objects
by using object level permissions
now you can give permissions to the
bucket you can just say
uniform access to all objects in the
bucket by using only bucket level
permissions so you can choose that you
can also go into advanced settings and
here you can see different ways in which
you can have configuration setup now you
can also have a retention policy to
specify the minimum duration where that
this bucket's object must be protected
from deletion and you can set a
retention policy will not get into all
that we will just first try creating a
bucket so just click on create and that
should create your bucket wherein i have
my bucket now i can click on overview to
see the details what is the region
which region it belongs what is the
storage class anytime you can always
click on edit bucket and make some
changes here you can look at the
permissions so bucket uses fine grained
access allowing you to specify access to
individual objects
and then you can basically look at who
has access to this so in my case
editors of the project they basically
are the bucket owners
owners of project viewers of the project
right and you can basically choose what
kind of access you need so for this
you can always go into cloud storage and
then you can decide what kind of access
you would want to give whether that's a
storage admin it's an object admin
object creator object viewer and so on
you can always look at storage legacy
and for any other services depending on
what apis you have enabled right you can
always control your permissions so right
now it is storage legacy bucket reader
and that's fine and this one
is bucket owner and then might be i was
using some other services like data proc
which uses cloud storage and that's why
i have given data proc service agent
also so these are some of the members
you can remove
you can view by specific members you can
view by roles so what are the different
roles which have access to this so it
says storage legacy bucket owner there
are two owners
based on this particular project so
these are auto controlled but then you
can add or remove machines you can save
storage cost by adding a life cycle rule
to delete objects after the duration of
current retention policy so you can add
different policies
and you can basically control your
bucket now my bucket is already created
right so i can go back and then i see my
bucket is already here i can click on
this option and you can anytime edit the
bucket permissions you can edit the
labels the default storage class you can
just go ahead and delete the bucket you
can export it to cloud pub sub so
basically if you would want to have the
content from this bucket
being accessible in a message queuing
system you can go for pub sub you can
process with cloud functions and you can
scan with cloud data loss prevention so
there are different options which are
available we can always select this
bucket and delete it now i can click on
the bucket
and that basically shows me different
ways in which i can upload some data
here so i can just click on upload files
and here then i can choose some files so
for example i'll go in here
i'll go into data sets and i have
different data sets so for example let's
choose this one which is a csv file
and then i'm just uploading this to my
cloud storage right it's as simple as
this so you can drag and drop your files
or you can just upload your files
and my file is uploaded here now i can
basically edit permissions for this one
right so this is in the bucket so anyone
who has access to this bucket can
basically download this file it can they
can copy move or rename this you can
export it and you can look at the
permissions of this file so let's look
at edit permissions and it says
for this project whoever is the owner it
has access i've also given a specific
user my gmail id and i've given access
so at any point of time you can just say
add item and then you can start giving
different kind of accesses
so let's click on cancel here now my
data is already uploaded into this
particular bucket and that's a simple
usage of your cloud storage
now what we can also do is i can
basically select this and i can delete
it i can also create specific folders
and then basically
load data into it i can click on this
one i can just do a download and then i
can download it anywhere on my machine
so let's go to desktop and let's
download this file so we not only
uploaded some content in the bucket but
we also downloaded that in a different
location which will be accessible now
what i could have also done is i could
have created a folder here and i could
have specified
say for example immediate immediate data
okay and i'm clicking on this one so
that's my immediate data i can click on
this one and now
i can upload my data specifically to
this particular folder by using the same
mechanism you can just do upload file
let's choose air passengers
let's do a open and my file will be
uploaded
so you can always choose what is the
retention expiry date for this one so as
of now there is nothing right but you
can be deleted objects can be deleted or
modified until there is a minimum
duration you can control all of that you
can basically download it right you can
copy it and you can move it and rename
it so this is a simple example where i
created a particular bucket right now if
for example you click on this transfer
so it says cloud storage data transfer
products have moved you can now find
storage transfer service premise data
and transfer appliance in new data
transfer section right so you can always
go back
to cloud storage you can also look at
transfer options which are mainly when
you are using your on-premise service
and you would want to upload data in a
google cloud right
so this is
my bucket here now i can go to cloud
console and here what i can do is if i
would be interested in working so i can
just say gsutil
right and then we have
for example let's try a help okay and
that basically shows me my gsutil now
you can always go to quick start gsutil
tool and this is one more way wherein
basically you can do it from the command
line so working with buckets so you can
do a gsu till mb minus b and then on a
particular zone if you would be
interested in and then you can say gs
colon and give a name so my awesome
bucket this is how you will create a
bucket
which will show you it is creating a
bucket and then basically you can upload
an image or some data from internet you
can just do a wget download the file and
then you can just do a gsutil copy
command and that basically will pick up
the file from your cloud shell location
put it in your bucket
once you have done that you can always
do a copy
right so here you are doing a copy from
your local machine that is your cloud
shell machine to your bucket and you can
do the reverse of that that is you can
do a copy and you can point your bucket
and the file and download it to your
desktops so you can just download that
using the command line
and you can copy the object to a folder
in the bucket so that is by creating a
particular folder and you are pushing
the file into a particular bucket you
can list the contents of a bucket using
ls and then give your bucket name so gs
colon so we can just try this one to be
simple and rest you guys can try so here
you can just do a gsutil
you can do a ls
gs colon slash
and then i need to give my bucket name
so in my case the bucket name was
my data important so let's try that so
let's say my data important and i'm
trying to list the bucket and the
content it has right and then you have a
folder and then you can look into the
folder and look into the files
so this is a simple quick option wherein
you can use your cloud shell you could
be using your google cloud sdk from your
local machine
or you can be using cloud console to
create a bucket upload some data on it
download the data see if the data is
accessible and that basically shows you
the power of cloud storage where you can
easily upload any kind of data now what
we can also do is as you're using a free
account or even a paid account unless
and until you would want to keep the
bucket you can select it and you can
just go ahead and delete it so this will
basically ask you to key in the bucket
name and let's say my data important
you need to confirm your bucket name
click on confirm and you could have done
that using gsutil and a delete command
from the command line that is from cloud
shell so we have now created a bucket we
have uploaded some data into it we saw
how you can download it or create a
folder and upload some specific data
into it and also you can do the same
thing using gsutil tools
wherein you can list your bucket create
your buckets delete it create some
folders into it and do everything from
the command line so this is in simple
way you can use your gcp where either
you can spin up your machines or you can
use cloud storage to basically use a
storage or a easy to use instance on
google cloud platform thank you and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here